captured on a CCTV camera a moment of
utter devastation
a passenger train and a freight service
colliding head on the explosion lighting
the night sky
the aftermath was a patchwork of Twisted
scarred carriages and human pain
dozens of people killed
this was Greece's deadliest rail Crush
in living memory those aboard described
hammock and a cacophony of Screams
when they crashed the passenger train
was probably doing more than 100 miles
an hour it was packed with around
350 people it must have been terrifying
train just started to jerk more and more
until we ended up at a 45 degree angle
so all the way to the front of the train
I went and saw to the front the worst
part of the Collision right in front of
me the whole train had bent 90 degrees
had fallen over the cliff and half was
hanging in the air the whole thing was
on fire
visiting the scene the Prime Minister
offered his condolences his transport
Minister was distraught
and not long after he resigned
the recovery has now been going on for
more than 24 hours not just looking for
survivors this is also a criminal
investigation
a crash like this one where two trains
run into each other at high speed on the
same bit of track should be Unthinkable
but it's happened here shocking but
maybe not a surprise because for a long
time unions and even the rail regulator
have been warning that the Greek system
is outdated and unsafe and now that
prediction has come true
the injured were brought to hospital in
the city of Larissa a long line of
casualties arriving during the day
and later a vigil outside the train
station where the passenger service made
its final stop before the crash what we
found was sadness and shock I feel angry
about this situation and sad very sad
and a lot of emotional
the station master has been arrested and
charged with manslaughter as the number
of dead Rises so too will the
recriminations and the questions about
how this could have happened
Adam Parsons Sky News Tempe northern
Greece